(audience cheering)
Wow!
It's kinda nice, huh?
Yeah.
You know, thanks so much for coming.
[Audience Member] I love you!
Oh, a guy loves you by the way.
(audience member screams)
Who is it, which one?
(audience laughs)
He's like, he thinks, No, me!
I have a chance now!
(audience laughs)
You know what, it's really nice,
I was so glad you could do the show.
I don't think, people don't know this,
but you were in the
audience at my audition.
Yeah, it was me seeing that tape.
Yeah, so you were at that.
It was so nice.
(audience awes)
Don't mock our nice moment!
Yeah, don't mock our real moment, yeah.
No, but that was obviously
a big night in my life,
but we of course, best friends at the time
and you came and you sat in the audition,
sat through the whole thing
and told me you can do it.
Through the whole thing, I know, ugh.
No, you were great, though.
Oh well.
That was really funny.
Yeah, I looked all droopy.
And what was I?
Why didn't you, the
least you could've done
is say buy a real jacket.
Don't use the Sears jacket
from your truck of your car.
Remember we were trying
to make it not a big deal.
Yeah, right, like it wasn't.
And you, at the time,
were going through a lot.
Yeah, I was.
Thanks for bringing it up.
I had gotten fired from Frasier.
Wait, what?
No, I just meant you
had a birthday recently.
(laughing)
I remember at the time
you were gonna do Frasier
and it didn't work out, the pilot,
and you were really upset
and I said something better's gonna.
Remember, I said something
better's gonna come along.
Yeah that's right.
See ya, yeah that's right.
(laughing)
I gotta go to the Late Night Thing.
See you sucker!
But I said something
better's gonna come along
and then it did.
Yeah, you were right.
I was just being nice.
This whole story was about you were right.
Exactly!
All the stories should be about me.
But you were really funny.
Oh please, no please, let's not do that.
And now you set up straight
and now I sit like this.
Yeah, I learned to sit upright.
It took me seven years.
And that was the whole key.
Yeah, right, exactly.
I wanted to mention something.
One thing that a lot of people don't know
about you that I know because
we were friends for so long
is your special dessert that you whip up
for your good friends that
I want to share with people.
I used to live like three
blocks away from Lisa.
This is back in the early
days, we're struggling.
Lisa always used to call me up
and say I'm making my special dessert.
Come on over and have some.
Her special dessert.
(audience cheering)
That so depresses me, but anyway. I
know, what til you hear what it was.
So I'd come over and her special dessert
was you would buy a big bag of M&M's,
pour them on a tray, put
them in the microwave,
and melt it into goo.
I'm laughing because it wasn't goo.
Yeah it was goo, yeah.
You would just melt it into goo
and you'd say it's an old family recipe.
The microwave is like 15 years old.
How can it be an old family recipe?
Because it originated in the toaster oven.
Which goes back to the 15th Century.
Very nice.
Yeah, I understand
you're getting a little,
you've been irritated
lately with the tabloids.
Is that true?
Well a little bit.
Not a huge amount, but you know,
they make things up.
And I don't have it as
bad as other people do,
so that's okay, but you know.
They make things up about you, too.
No, I have been in the
tabloids only twice.
And both of my made-up
stories were so lame.
Twice I've been in.
One was Conan O'Brien has
really high cholesterol.
And they just cut out around my head.
You know when they just cut out your head
so your head's just floating.
And they a picture like that.
And the other story was
they got a picture of me
just looking kinda confused or something
and they said Conan's pal says
he doesn't wash his hands
after using the bathroom.
(audience cheering)
Yeah, so thanks, Andy.
You know, there's only
so much nagging I can do.
I just always thought I want
a better story than that.
I want caught in love nest
with Gerry Ryan or something.
I know, make it something good
if you're just gonna plumb make it up.
They said Courtney and I were seen
at Pea in the Pod Maternity Shop.
Ah!
But we weren't, we weren't!
Yeah, but who cares?
That's not like a bad one.
I know, but why do they go
through the trouble to just,
you know, what can we do?
(laughing)
What do they think that's
gonna be really great?
I would love if a tabloid came out
and they just made up things
that weren't even that
interesting, you know?
Like Lisa Kudrow prefers
broccoli over carrots.
Exclamation point,
confused-looking picture of you.
Broccoli next to you.
And life is good, everything's fine?
Yeah, everything's really good.
I see you all the time,
so I know your husband, Michel.
Of course his family's from France.
And I'm curious do they get the show,
do they get Friends over there?
Yeah, it's really big, it's
really, really big in France.
It's big in France.
Yeah, so now most of his
relatives know who I am
and some of them just know.
This was the only thing I
didn't know how to take this,
some of them visited and then they left,
they called up Michel and said,
we had a really nice time, thank you.
And you know what, your wife got prettier.
Maybe that's a nice thing.
They weren't saying you
were a hideous ghoul before.
See that's what I hear.
Oh see, well that's therapy.
I hear she was a ghoul before and now,
thank god for you, lucky.
How do they show it in France?
Do they use subtitles?
They dub it.
Oh they dub it.
Well there's a cable.
They show subtitles, that's the cool one.
And then on the network TV it's dubbed.
I think it would be so weird
to see yourself dubbed.
I've never seen that.
But when you watch Friends dubbed
is it like, Well hello
Phoebe, how are you?
I am fine, Monica.
It's good to see you.
Is it like that?
I haven't really watched
it, I have to be honest.
I've only heard about it.
You've never met any of the people
that have done the voices
or anything like that.
No, but I've heard.
I've heard in Czechoslovakia,
there's one guy.
That's it for the whole show.
One guy does the voices
of everyone on the show?
At first I thought it was
one guy doing all the voices
and I found out he just narrates.
How do you narrate?
So it's me talking like, Oh
Chandler, you're so floopy
or whatever I would say.
And what is he translating to
the Czechoslovakian people?
Oh Chandler, you're so.
I don't know what he's doing.
Phoebe finds Chandler floopy.
Yeah, yeah.
Phoebe just made up a word.
Now she's leaving the
room and acting confused.
[Audience Member] Phoebe!
Very strange.
I'm just gonna be quiet.
Yeah, stop making people yell.
I'm sorry I'm making them yell.
Well we gotta go.
Friends is of course, like
I have to mention this.
It's so funny, I'd better tell
people when Friends is on.
Yeah, you better.
Thursdays at eight o'clock.
Help that fledgling show.
It's on NBC.
(audience cheering)
Lisa, thanks so much for coming.
So nice to have you.
Lisa Kudrow, everybody.
We'll take a break, we'll be right back.